foreign
[Music]
we're 18 points away from ending the
speedrun I end at 2300 mostly because
for the vast majority of players playing
these games over 2300 is going to get
really Technical and it's going to get
calculation heavy and I think the best
experience is yielded under 2300 so my
general plan after this speedrun is
complete there will be another one but
the YouTube content is going to be a
little bit more well divided between
speedrun and other stuff that I want to
prepare like the end game video but I
know this the speed run content is
something people really like so I don't
think there might there can be such a
thing as too much of it
all right let's get the show on the road
15 plus 10.
22.40 Flagger chess okay all right
Flagger chest well we're gonna play D4
again I want to get a a more solid D4
game than we did last time maybe we'll
get another Carl's bed
okay Knight F6 will play Mainline C4
and G6 King's Indian or grunfels we had
a king's Indian game a couple of weeks
ago um I want to say when I was about
2150 and in in that game I played the
Carlsbad oh not the Carl's but the ever
back variation so perhaps we'll get a
chance to repeat it if our opponent
plays King's Indian no but our opponent
plays the grunfeld now it's interesting
because the grinfeld is not all that
popular I would say really under you
know maybe Master Level uh USCF and fide
uh and you know 2240 standard rating on
chess.com corresponds usually to about a
2000 so you just don't see the grunfeld
every day at this level and there isn't
one reason for that I would say one of
the main reasons is that it requires
tremendous levels of memorization and
understanding it's one of the hardest
openings to learn it's like the Chinese
of of openings you know it's like a
completely different system of ideas and
Concepts that you have to fully Master
Plus an insane amount of theories so the
line that I with white have played
against the grunfeld for most of my life
is the one that I'm about to show you
C takes D5
now as those of you who played the
grunfeld know and even those who don't
play the grinfeld know White's main move
in this position is the very natural E4
and the grunfels I know this is kind of
a meme at this point is the ultimate
hyper modern opening if you were to
define hyper modern opening with a
single example it would be the grunfeld
because black literally says I do not
care about the center or so it seems
allows white to occupy the center with
pawns allows the pawn on C3 that
supports the pawn on D4 and still it's
considered one of the best objective
openings but the idea is so clear black
wants to push this C Pawn up to C5 and
then get the Knight out to C6 and get
the bishop out to G4 in the event that
white plays Knight F3 so in the grunfeld
black gives up the center and then
applies as much pressure on it as
possible as quickly as possible so if
you're not well versed in theory with
either side actually you can get in huge
trouble with white as well
so there's a gazillion lines against the
grunfels that are all viable it's it's
like any such opening the night or you
know King's Indian White has a choice of
maybe 10 12 viable continuations I like
a sideline here that gets most grunfeld
players out of theory and uh from a
practical standpoint it is quite hard
for black to equalize and the move is
Bishop to B5 check at this point this
move has become a little bit more
popular I I played it back in 2016 uh
when it was relatively unknown uh now of
course everything under the sun is known
the point of Bishop B5 check is actually
simpler than it appears you induce C6
and then you tuck the bishop away on A4
and you make it difficult for black to
play C5 you actually just delay uh the
move C5 of course if black castles then
now black is ready to play C5 but the
bishop on A4 is believe it or not quite
well placed here because it's sort of
slicing through Black's position in the
future of like it's the night out to C6
you could take it and this bishop could
also drop down at B3 and harass the F7
Pawn in certain other situations so here
the main move
uh if I remember correctly it's been a
while since I've reviewed my own
analysis here
is night out to E2
and the reason that you don't go Knight
F3 is because of the potential for
Bishop G4 here if black plays Bishop G4
then you can meet that with F3 chasing
the bishop away and keeping the Knight
intact of course Knight for me too what
is it doing uh well primarily it's
lending further support to White's
Center because we are preparing for the
uh very likely scenario
in which black starts to pressure our
center with C5 Knight C6 Etc so we have
to lay on the beef on this D4 Pawn so
that we avoid losing it or so that we
avoid having to push the pawn to D5 and
reopen this grun-filled bishop on G7
hopefully I'm explaining things
relatively clearly so far I'm not giving
you any variations we'll save that for
after the game but I'm trying to sort of
explain the conceptual underpinnings of
most of these grunfeld positions and
every line is different white has a
million ways to position their pieces so
take this with a grain of salt
so I'm expecting C5 as the theory of
this line has developed black grunfeld
players have come up with somewhat more
creative treatments in this position
earlier C5 was considered derigura was
like everybody was playing and now uh
Peter Spindler came along he is perhaps
the foremost runefield expert alongside
Maxima shilagravi as a great chessable
course on the grunfeld uh svidler I knew
I know started playing E5 in this
position which is not as common in the
grunfels but in this particular
variation it's a really good move and
there's another line where black
actually just pushes these Queen side
pods B5 and A5 and tries to develop some
Queen side pressure as well so lots of
good moves here for black let's see what
our opponent chooses
rishadon asks why does Knight F3 Bishop
G4 H3 not solve the bishop G4 issue well
remember that the function of the Knight
is to protect the center so if the
Knight is eliminated the move C5 comes
with far greater effect
if you had played Knight F3 Bishop G4 H3
trade on F3 then that's a perfect
example black plays C5 and you literally
cannot defend the pawn on D4 you're
gonna have to push that pawn up to D5
and as I'll explain after the game that
frequently uh comes with a pretty hefty
price tag
yeah E5 is a move here
B5 is a move here
C5 is a move you could also develop the
Knight to D7 so it and all of them are
or sorry this is after 92.
and I will confess that I don't remember
too much Theory here from the white side
so we're largely on our own
but I think we've succeeded in getting
our opponent out of theory
now believe it or not
I've seen some games in this variation
or white delays short castle and
actually just goes for checkmate with H4
and H5 because that attack comes really
really really quickly
um so if black starts pushing Queen side
pawns I think after B5 Bishop B3 A5
there's a line where white plays H4 and
things get incredibly tactical and of
course the engine always evaluates it as
zero zero zero
um so if you want to know what the like
best objective opening is against D4
there's no question that
grunfeld is better objectively than
Kings Indian C5 okay so our opponent
ends up playing the traditional way and
we don't no action is required as of yet
the pawn on D4 is protected one two
three times and it's attacked three
times so we don't need a fourth Defender
should we need a fourth Defender this
bishop is going to come out to E3 but
the top priority for now is of course
for us to get our King out of the center
let's Castle
here playing H4 is far less feasible
because our Center is already Under Fire
playing H4 would be way too Brazen with
the king in the center and the attack on
D4 comes really quickly so here we want
to play more positionally with short
castle and if black plays Knight C6 then
we're gonna get our dark squared Bishop
out to E3 to support the D4 Pawn
which is generally better than getting
the bishop to B2 because B2 is a really
lame Square I mean here it's literally
doing nothing except supporting the
center at least on E3 it's at least
controlling some other squares we can
play the move E5 somebody in chat is
asking can white play E5 in such
positions yeah you can play E5 but
remember when you push any pawn in the
center it creates weak squares that can
be occupied by your opponent's pieces so
think about which weak Square E5 creates
well it weakens the D5 square and black
can navigate the bishop over to that
square and that square could function as
a pretty serious Outpost so this
position isn't just all about playing
against the dark squared Bishop we also
have to maintain the structural
Integrity of our Center and that often
means keeping the pawns on D4 and E4 as
long as we can because they're
controlling all of these potential
developing squares uh in in the center
it's keeping black species at Bay
um now of course if if black plays E5 in
a position like this then we are very
likely to push D5 creating a
protected pass Pawn in the center so
rarely in the groonfield is black
combine E5 and C5 although it happens it
does happen
now an interesting observation I might
have misled you earlier
if black plays Knight C6 here
you know my my fancy isn't tickled At
All by Bishop takes E6 and Knight C6 is
played Bishop takes C6 on the surface
looks completely reasonable like you're
getting rid of a piece that's putting
pressure on your Center the problem is
that the light squares become incredibly
weak as a result so if you imagine the
position after Bishop takes C6 BC first
of all you're opening up a pathway for
the black Bishop to get to A6 harassing
the Knight on E2 second of all these
doubled C pawns are actually a great
asset for black because black can use
one of them to trade on D4 and then
simply bring the second Pawn up to C5
and we don't have another C Pawn to
bring up to C3 so we certainly don't
want to take that Knight on C6 instead
we want to uh bring out the
reinforcements and the move is Bishop B3
and I think it's fair to say that white
is a little bit better here I think
we're still following the main line
and if I remember correctly this is the
sort of Old Main Line this is what's
been played really for the past you know
10 20 years
um this knight from C6 in the grunfeld
also often goes to A5 and then to C4
that's a super typical maneuver instead
our opponent takes on D4 okay
okay and I think we have managed to
successfully defend our center Bishop D7
a little bit passive
here I think already it's pretty safe to
say that white has an edge out of the
opening
so how should we go about improving our
position well what What observations can
we make what what needs to be done
well one thing that I would like to get
done is get rid of this pin Against The
Rook on A1 so that should the necessity
arise we can push the pawn up to D5
without having to worry about losing our
Rook especially because the Rook on A1
is not doing anything and there's plenty
of things that it could be doing the
move that I like is Rook B1 I like Rook
B1 I like to induce the move B6 because
that softens up the Knight on C6 but a
case could also be made for Rook C1
perfectly reasonable move as well I
think both Rook B1 and Rook C1 to me
look
uh entirely feasible
but what else what else is on the menu
here You could argue that Rook B1 B6
actually helps blacken away
because it creates an anchor point on A5
for the Knight
uh so I think it's hard it's hard to say
whether Rook B1 or Rook C1 is better
if we play Rook C1
black will very likely play Rook C8
but then already I think we can go after
Black's A7 Pawn with the move D5
hmm let me think about this for a second
it's a difficult conceptual moment
difficult conceptual moment here
yeah actually B6
is a move that black often plays on
their own volition in the grunfels rugby
one might be inaccurate
Roku B1 might be inaccurate let's go
Rook C1
I like Rook C1 a little bit more
and The Rook is just a little bit more
active on the C file than it is on the B
file
um but I was talking
Savar OG about Rogue B1 B6 and then D5
or Rook C1 and then D5
that's precisely why we're moving The
Rook away from A1
there is a tactical detail that you
should be aware of in such positions
anytime
you see the Bishops staring at each
other like this you have to be
considering tactics connected with
Knight takes D4
so these tactics do not work as long as
the queen keeps in contact with the
bishop but if after Rook C8 for example
you'd you would play the natural move
Queen D2 just let's bring the queen up I
already think Knight takes D4 works
so Rook C8 Queen D2 Knight takes D4
Bishop takes D7 and then unfortunately
black can take the Knight on E2 with
check drawing Our Queen away and then
Queen takes D7 keeps the extra Pawn okay
I can show that after the game so you
don't have to worry about visualizing it
yeah and in the meantime let's try to
understand how we can go about improving
our position we can play the move F3
to create a little Pawn chain here and
and reinforce the pawn on e4 F3 of
course comes with some drawbacks as well
E6 okay never mind E6 is a big move
that's a big move that closes the bishop
yeah E6 looks positionally dubious to me
so it's a it's a pretty good sign that
our opponent has played it
but you have to understand that nothing
in such positions really happens fast
it's a quiet position
we're not ready to make a move like D5
which probably is tempting to some of
you because D5 doesn't yield anything
d5e takes D5 and then the Knight can
jump out to E5
And Trades generally favor the side you
know playing against the big Center so
we shouldn't really seek them out some
of you are proposing E5 but like I
explained earlier E5 creates a gaping
hole on D5 and one of the benefits of
Black's last move is that the knight
from C6 can now easily swing back to E7
and then toward D5 or it can do it
through B4
so it's too early to play E5 yeah I
don't want us to to immobilize our
Center just yet
Queen D2 again there is Knight takes D4
which is quite annoying because I really
do want to connect the Rooks
um one of the possibilities is to play
F3 just to reinforce our Center kind of
a neutral move
um
let's see what else we can do
I don't really want to move the Knight
away for me too
okay one move that we could consider is
actually Rook up to C5
Rook C5 is just one of those moves that
just sort of improves the position that
Rook is hard to get rid of
um so Rook C5 kind of attracts
is is vaguely attractive to me
but then he goes Rook C8 and maybe then
we can already go D5
let's do it let's play Rook C5
let's play Rook C5 and it's it's it's a
move that isn't all as committal as it
may appear because oh but what if black
plays B6 first of all B6 here fails to
the obvious Rook takes C6 but even in a
scenario where black moves the Knight
away from C6 let's say and plays P6 big
FD like we can just move the Rook back a
lot of people don't conceptualize this
properly like moving a piece up isn't
inherently committal because you can
always just move it back down again and
this is not the kind of position where
every Tempo is going to be all that
important like oh you know we can't make
a move and then bring the piece back
so Rook C5 is one of those General
improving moves that accumulates the
pressure
and it also prepares D5 because after
d5e takes D5 we can now recapture with
the rook and all of a sudden the queen
of The Rook combined to put massive
pressure on this vulnerable Bishop on D7
so in a way E6 this move has created a
hook that we can use to push our
quantity 5.97 so the ball is back in our
court we have to decide whether to trade
light squared Bishops if we compare the
health of our Bishop versus our
opponent's Bishop the enter probably
would be no because the bishop on D7 is
a pretty lame piece on the other hand
trading gives us another Tempo which we
can use to bring our Queen out let's say
to B3 so that is a sensible option as
well
Bishop B3 black will go Rook C8 probably
but the positive there is that we can
already go Queen D2 I want to keep the
Bishops I don't want
to trade too many pieces here
hard to decide but let's go Bishop B3
so B6 is what I'm expecting and then
we'll move the Rook back to C1 great
example of not being afraid to do that
okay Rook CA
we certainly don't want to allow Rook
take C5 because that would ruin our
entire Pawn Center so let's trade a pair
and finally we'll be able to bring our
Queen up to D2
without having to worry about any Knight
takes D4 shenanigans
so my assessment of this position is
probably a very small Edge for white we
are not playing for anything big here
the grunfeld is a ridiculously solid
opening
so get ready for a long and drawn out
positional battle here
doesn't our Bishop stare at a wall of
Pawns yeah I know exactly D5 is now a
serious idea in the future not
immediately but in the future absolutely
the bishop on B3 is supporting the pawn
break D5
but the other thing of course is that
not every piece has to be Distributing
the covet vaccine
Bishop on B3 isn't the greatest piece of
all time but it is it's controlling some
squares in the center
there's no great place for our light
skirt Bishop here
um so it might as well chill on on B3
for now
so I think our our subsequent plan of
action here is pretty straightforward
we're going to bring a rook into the
game I don't know if we're going to play
Rook C1 or Rook D1 just yet depends on
how black continues
I definitely like the look of F3
to support the E4 Pawn a move that we
were considering earlier
and you know eventually we're probably
preparing the move D5 like eventually we
will push D5 especially if we can get
that pawn all the way to D6
in fact D5 is already a semi-legit
candidate move but it is still premature
so here an instructive moment I think
most people
When comparing between Rook D1 and Rook
C1 would say well
you know I've mentioned many times that
if there is only one open file you want
to be the one occupying it but Rook C1 I
think
fails to account for the fact
that black after getting the bishop out
is going to play Queen D7 and then Rook
C8 so Rook C1 is kind of a veiled Rook
trade because we will not be able to
cement our control of the C file before
black brings his own Rook over to C8 and
I actually think we should keep a pair
of Rooks on the board the side of the
space Advantage should try to keep more
pieces on the board and for that reason
I think more to the point is actually
bringing the Rook to D1 the C file is
endless of course let's play F3 to
support the pawn
the C file is not where the party is at
nothing is happening on the C file it
would be nice if we could infiltrate to
C7 but we cannot do that defending the
C7 square a second time is going to be
very hard
so
I think our pieces are very compactly
placed our Center is super well
protected and it's kind of hard for
black to make improving moves here
yeah we can we can consider this classic
idea of H4
which sounds drastic like whoa you're
pushing a Pawn on the same side Your
Castle but our King is ridiculously safe
black has zero attacking prospects and
H4 is very typical in positions where
black has this hook on G6 we want to
push the pawn to H5 and are we trying to
Checkmate black in three moves no we
just want to make an annoying move and
we want to pose black with a decision so
H4 to me is kind of a no-brainer in such
positions
notice that we're still maintaining the
general Integrity of our Pawn structure
it's not like we're pushing the G Pawn
or something all right we're making a
small investment of course we're
weakening our King a little bit
but we want to bring the spawn to H5
potentially all the way to H6 in order
to create the precedent for mating ideas
on the back rank
um and if black plays H5 then that
creates for us a relatively juicy
outpost on G5 which we can park the
bishop on of course trying to induce the
incredibly weakening move F6
so your mentality in these positions
should not be I want to come up with a
plan that's going to result in Victory
in four moves there is no such plan
we're making small gradual improving
moves we're trying to be annoying get
black and time pressure and the move H4
fits the bill in that regard
if hopefully that makes it's hard to
understand these moves without first
understanding that we are adopting the
sort of okay gradual Soviet Grandmaster
I don't know very small improving moves
okay so let's see whether black plays H5
or not that will dictate our subsequent
course of action
bubanesh suggests Knight C3 and D5 yeah
reasonable but I think that will just
lead to a ton of Trades
right D5 is of course as I mentioned one
of our main ideas but if you play it too
quickly or if you play it under the
wrong circumstances it's going to have
the opposite effect it's just going to
result in a bunch of Peace trades and
potentially an equal end game
so to me D5 is is something that we are
keeping an eye on but it isn't really
like something I Envision us playing in
the next you know five seven moves
I think we should exhaust our improving
moves first on the sides of the board
keep it in our back pocket yeah
ship King asks would you go Bishop H6
I'm sure people watching this on YouTube
were wondering the same thing Bishop H6
is so typical when you hear when you
have this battery so from a purely like
positional standpoint obviously Bishop
H6 is good for white because we trade
off the grunfeld bishop on G7 and we
create more weaknesses on the king side
and I think now that black has played
the move H5 and further softened up
these dark squares on the king so you
know this square and this square and
that square and what are all these
squares defended by well it's that
grunfeld Bishop so I like to move Bishop
H6 we might play it the drawback is that
we do you know the bishop on E3 was a
very nice solidifying piece you know it
was really sort of helping us make sure
that our Center is Compact and well
protected but you could also argue that
that is the same role fulfilled by the
Knight on E2 the Knight is doing a
perfectly good job of reinforcing the
pawn on D4 and I agree with that and I
think black is sufficiently passive to
where we can get away with this move
yeah but some of you are saying why
don't we do step six first but nobody's
gonna play F6 if we play Bishop G5 that
was either our other candidate move
but I think Bishop H6 is a little bit
more decisive
and you know maybe against a slightly
lower rated player I would recommend
this technique of like playing Bishop G5
because a lot of people would play F6
and that would be a horrible horrible
suicidal move
so the other thing you should understand
is that Bishop H6 is a um limited time
offer because if black would have moved
his Rook from f8 then already Bishop H6
could be met with the typical Bishop h8
a technique that you should be
intimately familiar with to save your
fiancated Bishop so this is perhaps our
last opportunity to trade that Bishop
since the Rook is still on f8 and black
can't move the bishop away
but what is our subsequent idea we're
going to get the Bishops off the board
well if black takes on H6 then we might
very well just play for checkmate we
could take and we could get our Knight
to F4 and maybe sack it on H5 that comes
really really quickly in fact Bishop A6
is our opponent's move first of all
well actually let's think for a second
there is technically no hurry to take on
G7 The Bishop's not going anywhere for
the time being
but we should ask her like is there a
point to not take on G7 because if there
isn't then we should just get it over
with
and the benefit of Bishop takes G7 is
that after King takes G7 we can drop our
Knight into F4 we can't play that move
here because it severs the connection
between the queen and the bishop
blunders the bishop on H6
so whether or not we take on G7 depends
on where we want to put our Knight
afterward I see two appealing options
for the Knight the first is F4 which is
what I just pointed out the second is to
move the Knight over to G3 and maybe
actually go for a direct King side
attack so let's say Knight G3 then we
want to take the bishop and park the
queen on G5 creating the threat of
Knight takes H5 check
so and of course the drawback of Knight
G3 is that the Knight is not
participating directly in preparing the
move D5
so it's a hard decision to make we can
take on G7 and go Knight F4 or we can
play Knight to G3 in this position if we
want to basically play for checkmate
so let me let me think about this for a
moment
okay
I think we should go
Knight G3 we're gonna play for mate
risky could backfire but I think Knight
F4 is just a little bit toothless
because if we had put a knight on F4
the key difference is that we are
closing the path for for the queen to G5
that is what because the 994 does the
same thing that the Knight on G3 does
but from G3 we are not closing the
pathway for the queen to get to G5 if
that makes sense
so of course again we're not afraid of
black taking on H6 by all means get our
own Queen to H6 thank you very much
on the next move we're going to trade on
G7 I assume black is going to play Rook
d8 that that to me seems like kind of a
no-brainer type of move
then we're going to trade Bishops and
we're going to park the queen on G5
and we're gonna have a significant
amount of threats on the king side
hopefully our play is making sense too
everything is pretty much
straightforward and logical
okay our opponent is really down on the
clock also
I should keep that in mind
what are the threats after King AJ well
that's something I'll explain after King
h8 is played that's when I was
dedicating my like 30 second thing to
okay Rook data is played let's do this
now something to notice like the sac on
H5 is way premature because there's just
no pieces right Sac on H5 Queen G5 check
is just two empty checks black will
cover with the Knight and we're at a
dead end so that's out of the question
let's dive in with Queen G5 as we had
planned now a lot of you are looking at
this and saying well I don't get what
our follow-up is after black moves the
king away from the G file so the thread
is obviously Knight takes H5 what is it
that we're gonna do after black Perry is
the threat by moving the king away
uh well it depends on where black puts
the king if King h8 then we can give a
check on F6 or an H6 and that looks very
sexy
King H7 I think is the best move
and then I had two separate ideas that
we are going to weigh and decide
of course nobody has canceled that our
old idea of pushing the d-pawn up to D5
and with the additional kingside
pressure
opening up another front so to speak in
the center could really overwhelm
Black's defenses another subtle maneuver
that I'm noticing is after we play D5 if
the pawns are traded that knight from G3
has now opened up a new pathway from E4
to F6
and the second pathway that's been
opened in the event of D5 ed585 the
bishop on B3 can suddenly drop back to
C2 and if you imagine the black king on
H7 the bishop will be pinning the G6
pawn and the threat of Knight takes H5
is going to be reinforced so that's idea
number one idea number two is very
similar
we can carve that pathway out ourselves
we can push the E Pawn up to E5 now you
might well didn't I say that this move
is bad well it was bad earlier and its
drawback is still very much the same
right it weakens the D5 Square it gives
black a big Outpost but if we're playing
for checkmate as you know you have to
make some positional concessions and E5
creates the maneuver 94 Knight F6 and
can allows the bishop to drop back to C2
much like in the event that we play D5
so I like D5 because I think it contains
the same strong points of E5 but none of
the drawbacks
um an opening of the center is is in our
favor
so I really really like the look of D5
here
and I don't see a single compelling
reason
for us not to play it let's go let's go
D5
because if black ignores I mean we're
threatening D takes E6 notice that the
bishop protects the Rook on D1
everything's protected there's e takes
D5 okay briefly let's consider Bishop
takes D5 because that is a viable move
the reason I don't like it as much is it
leaves The Rook on D1 undefended and so
we don't threaten any discovered checks
or discovered attacks after Bishop takes
D5 let's stick to our plan e takes D5
but it's good practice in general when
you have multiple ways to recapture even
if you had a move in mind to just give
it a couple of seconds of thought
because sometimes you'll realize that
there is a recapture that you didn't put
it sufficient thought into that just
ends the game
what do you get out of E60 Bible I just
explained the two main things pathway
for the Knight pathway for the bishop
but the third thing is that hey this is
a path pawn and it's threatening to move
up to D6 and that additional strain on
Black's position is going to be too much
to handle I think black is essentially
losing here blacks pieces are not just
not active enough to to defend against
all of the different sources of danger
that we are imposing on him
and something's going to give whether
it's going to be a sacrifice on H5
whether it's going to be pushing the
pawn up to D6 maybe Black's Glock will
run out One Thing One Way Or Another
We're going to get our way get our way
here
we're going to impose our well
it was equal for a while but now it's no
longer equal
okay F5
and of course this is the kind of move
that reeks of desperation but it's not a
bad move it's an understandable move
black is trying to prevent Knight E4 and
black is trying to restrict our light
skirt Bishop so this is where I think we
should revert back to our initial trump
card which is of course the D5 Pawn and
all of you should be itching to play the
move D6 which is a move we can largely
play without calculating because it
certainly is not going to hurt it
certainly is not going to hurt because
now we're reopening the bishop
we're reopening the line of fire on
Black's Rook on d8 and I'm already
seeing a tactic that stems directly from
that it's a sexy tactic and it only
works if black plays Knight G8 if black
plays Knight C6 I think we're gonna win
in a more mundane way
but let's hope for Knight G8 okay
Nightshade is on the board
so what do I notice well what I notice
is that the queen on D7 is the only
Defender Of The Rook on d8 I also
noticed that the pawn on G6 is a massive
weakness how do I know that well the
moment black played F5 I reassessed the
situation and I asked myself what new
weaknesses have been created and if you
ask yourself that question then
obviously G6 is the main one and here
simple deflection tactic yeah Bishop B6
is winning but even more to the point
is Bishop F7 yeah Bishop F7 attacking G6
Queen takes F7 is absolutely forced
otherwise this is Checkmate and then we
take the rook and promote our pawn and
we win the game yeah that's all this is
over
yeah this is a nice move it's pretty
simple but
it's a good way to cap off the attack
yeah Queen F7 Queen d8
Knight F6 okay so now a lot of people
you know you shouldn't get over excited
you shouldn't play Queen takes F6 that's
a horrible blunder you should win this
as simply as possible which is something
I've been imploring people to do from
the very beginning your Technique your
default technique should be just to play
straightforward chess the tactics should
only come in in the case of necessity
well what's the simplest move not even
Queen E7 your your impulse here should
not be your impulse number one should
not be the trade it should just be to
push your d-pawn just D7
just go D7
now you don't need to trade Queens here
you're threatening now to play Queen
takes F6 and d8 equals Queen
yeah D7 is much simpler than Queen E7
although Queen E7 of course is is
totally winning as well
yeah and I wouldn't even want to trade
Rooks here because rookie won rookie
seven is an idea that yields
you know an even faster picture yeah
four
we can do whatever the heck we want we
can play Queen takes F6
but if we want to play clinically
I think the simplest approach
is to play
let me think for a second there is still
one trick that we want to avoid
I don't think queenie7 was better Andrew
I think D7 is the best move
you know what the absolute simplest is
just move the queen away from d8
just move the queen queen C7
Queen C7
that's really the simplest move because
d8 Queen is Unstoppable and if black
gives the Knight away then we take back
with a rook and we win the queen anyway
so we're not even going to move the
Knight on G3 we don't need it it's done
its job
okay Knight D5
and now d8 Queen would be a very bad
move because black would be able to take
the other Queen with a knight
but you should be your hand should
already be reaching for this move this
Rook takes D5 Queen takes D5 it is
important that promoting results in an
discover check against the king
otherwise black would have like check on
D1 and we would still have to calculate
check
and made on the next move because or we
win the queen
it's all over Daniel lost
okay Queen D7 takes
and queen h8 made
GG
GG
that was actually a really nice game
that one was was more satisfying the
last couple we've had
so there's a lot to unpack so settle
down because we
I have a lot to explain we we've only
faced the we've never faced the crimpled
I want to say
um in the speed run so I always like
facing new openings
all right
so remember that the difference between
the king's Indian and the grundfold and
the King's Indian black plays the
immediate Bishop G7
and allows white to occupy the center
with three or potentially four pawns I
played the king's Indian with black
and from the white side I recommended
the averback variation Bishop E2 castles
in Bishop G5
you can refer back to the recent ever
back speedrun game if you want to know
more about this but the grunfeld is a
completely different opening is it
related to The King's Indian absolutely
both are hyper modern openings in both
cases black gives away the center
and then tries to attack it with his
pieces
but the grunfeld is a opening where the
center is a lot more open as a rule as a
matter of fact as a rule than in the
king's Indian like if you know the first
thing about the Kings Indian you know
that
the most typical structure if we go down
the main line This is the classical Main
Line the most popular variation E5
castles Knight C6 in almost all lines
white plays D5 and you get
a closed Center position where you have
opposite sides attack right wide attacks
on the queen side black attacks on the
king side and that gives the Kings
Indian a sort of distinct flavor
in the grundfold it's a totally
different kettle of fish because black
not only gives away the center but black
also tries to open it up
and the position is a lot more open and
so you get a lot more tactics a lot more
quickly than in the king's Indian and
the King's Indian the tactics are back
loaded to the middle game in the
grunfeld the tactics are often front
loaded to the opening because black very
quickly starts to assault White's
opening with White's center with C5 and
Bishop G7 and all that stuff and that's
also why you have to know what you're
doing with white
uh because you can easily just get
destroyed
um if you play obvious moves
so
as in these types of openings white has
a gazillion different setups C takes D5
is not forced so Knight F3 is a very
popular move and one of the most popular
modern setups is just to basically play
this like a London Knight F3 and Bishop
F4 castles E3
and what you'll notice if you look at
grenfell theory is that black often
plays C5 getting this Pawn Square super
super typical situation in the grundfold
this is a theoretical line
another way that white can play without
taking on D5 is the Russian variation
Queen B3 you're trying to get black to
be the one to take on C4 which creates
some interesting subtleties
another very topical line
and uh you also have Bishop G5
variations Bishop G5 can be played in a
bunch of different positions you can
play it here it can be played
immediately in this position
and if you want to play more
conservatively you can play the move E3
nothing wrong with this I mean this
gives black pretty easy equality but
this is a totally viable system as well
uh so what do you do when you have all
four of those bonds creating tension
well uh you can you can dig around on
your own but I can tell you that the
main line after Bishop F4 castles E3 C5
um it's less complicated than it looks
uh normally white plays D takes C5 and
black gets this queen out to A5 an idea
that you should be familiar with and if
you just start gobbling then there are
some straightforward tactics here uh
here black is already better C takes D5
is a serious mistake who can tell me why
who can spot preferably somebody who
doesn't play the grinfeld Black can you
figure out what blacks little mini
tactical idea here is okay well Queen
takes C5 is not a tactic
Knight takes D5 is correct
so you got the queen A5 to pin the
Knight on C3 and if Queen takes D5 then
Bishop takes C3 check
and you cannot take hero white is
already losing because here you drop the
Rook on A1 with for no comp
and if you don't take well what do you
do only everything is collapsing Rook is
coming to d8
Etc
so for this reason the main line I think
is Queen to A4
and here black recaptures on C5 and
white can pursue the queen with Queen B5
this is a well-known line
and to my knowledge the end game is
equal Knight takes B5 Knight A6 covering
C7 and black is doing completely fine
so this is one of many many theoretical
lines in the grunfeld
um but we decided to go for the main
line C takes D5 Knight takes D5 and of
course E4
now black trades on C3 and plays Bishop
G7 this is yet another tabia and a tabia
is a position from which branch out a
bunch of different lines
uh and this is there can be multiple
tabias in an opening multiple positions
in which one side has a vast choice of
different lines and essentially white
has a gazillion different ways here to
uh to develop his minor pieces his or
her minor pieces the most popular line
the line that's in terms of raw
popularity and in terms of longevity
this used to be what almost all of the
top players played and for a while it
was super fashionable it's still played
at the top level it hasn't been refuted
but black has found multiple setups that
yield good play it's Bishop C4
castles or black can start with C5 it
doesn't matter it's a transposition and
now the Knight once again comes out to
E2
so just to illustrate how quickly things
can the wheels can come off let's say
you play Knight F3 totally reasonable
move right well already
things start getting very dicey Bishop
G4 is a serious blunder don't miss the
classic Bishop takes F7 Knight G5 idea
so first you should Castle you should
play Knight C6
but let's say you Castle White Castles
already after CD CD Knight C6 white has
to be very careful in order to equalize
because after Bishop let's say Bishop B5
oh sorry Bishop E3 black plays Bishop G4
and now you have it right the classic
nightmare grunfeld situation where black
threatens to take the Knight and then
win the pawn on D4
D5 as it turns out is possible but is
hot is a hard move to play because you
drop A1 and if you play E5 black can
still play Bishop takes F3 if Queen
takes F3 then you drop the pawn on D5
and D4 and E5 is falling shortly
thereafter and if you have to play this
incredibly ugly move this type of
structure is terrible for white the
Knight is coming around to D5
and this is like every grunfeld player's
dream
so just one of many illustrations that
show you have to be theoretically well
prepared from the white side and that's
why people put their Knight on E2 so
that Bishop G4 can always be met with
the move F3 and so the main line that
I'm talking about goes as follows Knight
C6 Bishop E3
castles castles and for very many years
for decades everybody from the black
side played this weird looking line cdcd
Bishop came out to G4 anyway to induce
F3 and now the Knight drops into A5
counter-attacking the bishop
Bishop has to move and now Black's
Bishop has to move and it moves back to
E6 to contest the C4 Square this
position has been unbelievably well
studied thousands of games white has
this very common exchange sacrifice
white plays D5
sacrificing The Exchange but rooting out
Black's grundfeld bishop and this isn't
even really a sacrifice because White's
going to play Bishop H6 on the next move
and Force black to give the Rook back
away with F6
so again the point of the speedrun isn't
to just analyze a bunch of openings that
nobody plays you can do your own
research there's plenty of material in
the group I'm just trying to give you a
sense of the flavor
um you know it's almost like
trying different Cuisines right even if
you don't plan opening it's still a good
idea to be well versed in the basic
ideas of openings you don't play I I
feel very strongly about this and I
think it's something that's not said
enough and not done enough people just
choose their openings and then they
don't expose themselves at all to
anything else
um but in the game we played Bishop B5
check which in terms of popularity
I can tell you by number how far removed
it is from the most popular line
so let me just pull up reference
um
okay
so in this position
yeah so Bishop C4 is the top line then
there's Knight F3 then Bishop B3 number
three so Bishop B5 check gets honorable
mention fourth in terms of popularity
and the idea as I've explained is to
make it harder for black to push this
Pawn to C5 in one Fell Swoop
now C6 is not forced black can cover
with either the bishop or the Knight on
D7 we won't get into that C6 is the main
line Bishop A4 castles 92 and this is an
important position as we were talking
about during the game
looking at a reference on chess space
I'm seeing that most of the top guys in
the last couple of years have played
either B5 or E5 C5 is still the most
popular move
but all of the cool kids tend to play E5
here
and then the line goes as follows White
Castles
black plays Knight D7
white plays Bishop E3 of course
and now one of the positive byproducts
of the movie five is the black has this
very nice E7 square that he can park his
Queen on
and if you just sort of nonchalantly
play F3 this is voice against Iranian to
Paul of Shira from 1998.
apparently Rook d8 is very strong
creating an x-ray against the Queen the
DePaul of sure of game continued as
follows okay so DePaul of goddess Queen
out of there
and now shirov initiates a campaign to
uh rest control of the C4 square that C4
square is a really nice jumping off
point for the Knight so how do you think
sure of gathered his pieces develops his
pieces to exert maximum control over the
C4 Square what did he do
I'm looking for two moves
so first you play
Knight B6
and after Bishop B3 you play Bishop E6
exactly so the C4 square is controlled
what does it do well it makes it harder
for white of course to play C4 in the
future and it's just a very nice Square
for the Knight
and I think the position here is
approximately equal Rook ad1
now Knight C4 Bishop C1 and B5 by shiraf
to establish the Knight on the Square
now to follow up with a counter strike
on the other side of the board things
got wild and eventually sure of one but
this is just you know a good
illustration of how sharp this E5 line
is
and I also pointed out that B5 is a move
also very fashionable
move B5
um and after B5 let's see what the cool
kids play White normally plays Bishop B3
black now plays Bishop B7
and H4 was a famous game between adibon
the Indian Grandmaster and svidler
where both players followed a crazy
computer Line This was both of their
prep up until the draw watch this C5
striking in the center Addy bun just
closes his eyes and says I'm attacking
H5
Bishop takes E4 F3 Bishop D5 now the H
file opens hghg adibon plays Bishop H6
so far totally logical after Bishop
takes B3 white makes a Nutty move this
is a great attempt but unfortunately for
white it doesn't really yield more than
a draw
does anybody see
what white could do here let's see who
can find this move thank you someplace
Ian here for barbecue for the Primes
hint obviously he's not taking the
bishop back yeah
not Queen why Queen B1 that makes zero
sense
there is only one queen move that makes
sense guys that's not Queen takes B3
yeah I guess two queen D2 and queen C1
yeah Queen D2 is what adibon plays the
idea of course is to trade on G7 and
then play Queen H6 check but as it turns
out black can just move the bishop away
black can just move the bishop way
because this is not checkmate
of course this is Checkmate but the king
can actually move up to F6 and as it
turns out white does not have sufficient
Firepower to achieve more than a draw
white achieves a draw easily with a
check like this and black certainly does
not want to give the rook in the corner
but King G7 Queen H6 is a Perpetual
checks Fiddler played it a little bit
differently but this is essentially how
the game ended
um so anyways you have all these lines
but in the game our opponent plays the
traditional main line with C5 C5 castles
Knight season this is a lot more
positional than the B5 lines and even
the E5 lines okay so Bishop E3
now as I explained during the game you
normally want to refrain from playing D5
too early because this gives black
control not only of well not only does
it activate Black's Bishop but it gives
black control of all these dark squares
in the center you know
um sorry gives by control of all these
dark squares the E5 square and and the
other thing is that the plot on D5 can
be undermined in the future by black
pushing the pawn up to E6
so you know yeah as as cool as the pawn
looks here it's really not that
impressive I think Knight A5 is supposed
to be the best move here
actually
and the reason this is better than
Knight E5 is because Knight E5 allows
the additional F4 with Tempo so Knight
A5 is is very common in the groonfield
you will see the Knight chilling on A5
frequently because it's yeah Knights on
the rim or grim and whatnot but the
Knight can jump into C4 at a moment's
notice
so for that reason we play Bishop B3
and now if memory serves me right the
the only move that's approved of by
theory is actually still Knight A5
and then I was analyzing a line where
white actually moves the bishop up to B5
to cover C4
and if black plays A6 the bishop tucks
itself back to D3 and white gets a nice
compact position the engine usually
gives white a very small edge here the
way our opponent played at cdcd Bishop
D7 I see that people have played like
this but it's not all that impressive
it's kind of passive and I think black
basically accepts a slightly worse
position
now it's interesting
is that now that I look at this position
from an analytical perspective I think
there was a move that I didn't give
enough attention to which actually might
have been a better way to play for an
advantage I think this was a good
opportunity to play D5
I think this was a good opportunity to
play defy now first of all this is not
even a sacrifice because Bishop A1 you
play DC and both of the Bishops are
hanging White's gonna get two pieces for
a rook but you're like well didn't you
just say
that you want to avoid the move D5 in
such positions well there's one key
exception and the exception is if you
can follow up the move D5 by essentially
getting rid of Black's grundfeld Bishop
sticking our own Bishop on the weak
Square created by the move not even the
weak square and the square created by
the move D5 situation has changed and if
black plays Knight A5 we can now play
even immediately the move Bishop D4
and we can go for the trade a favorable
trade getting rid of black grunfeld
Bishop is almost always favorable this
would have been a very interesting
resource
and I see that the engine
approves of it as well the engine
actually says white should not hurry
with Bishop DeForest play Rook C1 first
yeah because after Bishop D4 blackened
closed the center down with E5 still I
like White's position here
Bishop C5 rookie a normally if you can
get this structure
White's gonna be not much better black
is solid but a little bit better
but anyways we we decided to play Rook
C1 which is a pretty normal if E6 is
good
Rook C5 actually the top move
all right all right we'll take it Rook
C5 97 and Bishop B3 keeping all of the
minor pieces on the board maintaining
the tension
and preparing to improve our position
with Queen D2 and Rook fc1
so a question in the chat if B3 why Rook
C5 to Rook C1 instead of Rook C2
so it'll be easier to potentially know
oh great question so the question is if
black had played B6 would we go Rook C2
or Rook C1 I think both moves are fine
um the downside of Rook C2 is that after
black plays Rook C8 you you can't double
I mean if you could play Rook fc1 here
then absolutely you would play Rook C2
but if you move your queen up then black
kind of Beats you to the punch takes and
you don't normally want to occupy a file
with a queen I've talked through that
before the reason why is that the queen
is just not a good piece uh with which
to uh control a file when it's alone
because the Rook always knocks the queen
out does that make sense so for this
reason I actually think here we would
probably play Rook C1 so that we could
meet Rook CA with Queen D2 but in
general you're right if you're moving
The Rook back and you are anticipating
that you will double in the future it's
a good idea to not bring it back all the
way but to leave open a space for the
other Rook to save yourself a little
time that is a totally legit uh Motif a
positional idea
uh but it's all about the concrete
you know specifics of the position
all right
so Rook C8
we we trade and we play Queen D2
okay black plays B6 uh repurposing the
bishop to B7 we play Rook D1 this should
be seven F3 this is all very
straightforward I like the move Queen D7
and I really think the game-winning idea
I really think the gaming idea was this
move H4 this is really one of the big
takeaways from this game these types of
moves can be so so so nasty for the
opponent for many different reasons
right it forces black to make a decision
which a lot of people don't like It
prepares just to play H5 and H6 and it's
sort of damned if you do damned if you
don't if you play H5 then you weaken the
dark squares if you don't play H5 then
we play H5 and you start regretting it
yeah exactly all of White's pieces have
been optimized like every one of our
pieces is doing something
efficient and just by process of
elimination there's just not much you
can do other than to start using your
pawns uh to to apply more pressure
so you might look at this so I don't get
how the pawn being on H5 actually helps
it's important to point out here that
you're not doing this this is not the
same as a pawn storm when you have a
rook on the H file right if you compare
this instance of H4 and this instance of
H4 these are two completely different
uses of the move H4 here you're playing
H4 with the express intent of opening up
the H file for your Rook here you're
playing h4h5 not to take on G6 this
would be you know just kind of defeat
the purpose probably not a terrible move
but H6 is the idea in order to get a
situation where the black king is now
deprived of its Luft Square why is that
important because we are anticipating
the center getting open you can actually
play D5 here
after e takes D5 Bishop takes D5 you can
hopefully already see how black is
greatly hurt by this Pawn on H6 it's
just a you know it's just a bone in
Black's throat
and I've actually previously talked
about the fact that pawns on H6 when the
opposing side is castled on G8 is just
almost always a really really unpleasant
thing to have to deal with because of
the long-term tactical potential created
by this Pawn it's not all about oh where
is the Checkmate on the next move it's
just you have to understand in the long
run black is going to have to suffer
with this Pawn which is also incredibly
well defended
so for this reason I think H5 is
probably the correct decision but now we
dive into H6 eliminating black strongest
piece Bishop A6 and Knight G3 I think is
very accurate here
if H5 wasn't played then would Bishop H6
ever still be primary no I mean if black
doesn't play H5 then we we want to play
H5 H6 it's more important for us to
shove that pawn through to H6 than it is
for us to trade Bishops on H6 I don't
actually know what black should have
done I feel like we played a very very
nice game I'll check the accuracy
afterward
but Bishop H6 Bishop A6 Knight G3 is
really the beginning of the end for
black
I don't think the position is lost for
black I would estimate like plus one
plus 1.5 it's really really bad but I'm
sure the engine the engine always finds
ways to defend in such cases
so Peter says the computer
says Queen B5 instead of H5 yeah maybe
Queen B5 makes sense actually Queen B5
is a way to actually prevent H5
but it's a hard move to find it's like a
one of those weird lateral moves
now we can play Knight F4
and reinforce the threat of H5 but now
after black plays H5 we've gotten an
undesirable version because we want to
be able to play Bishop H6
um
is Bishop yeah apparently it's it's
already plus two well
so Bishop H6 Bishop A6 Knight G3 is
Bishop A6 a wasted move yeah probably
probably black should have played but I
don't know what what else black can do I
mean we're gonna play Knight G3 anyway
so of course maybe Rook d8 was slightly
better but now we take and go Queen G5
and now the Knight can actually jump out
to F4 as well
so Bishop A6 kind of forced our hand but
Knight G3 is just such a nice Square
rook d8 and after Queen G5 I think we're
already winning after Queen G5 I think
we're already winning I think black's
Last Chance was perhaps to
I really don't know what exactly what
black should have done here but somehow
allowing Queen G5 I think is just
winning because
H7 D5 we're just coming at him from all
sides
and I'm confirming that all of these are
top moves ede
F5
and what's interesting is that D6
apparently is a serious inaccuracy the
best move was the simpler rookie one
and if the Knight moves back then we
dive into E6 same idea by the way right
we're over extending Black's Queen
either the queen has to protect the Rook
or give up G6
so
rookie one was the clinical move Knight
takes D5 oh now such a sexy tactic so
watch this of course Bishop takes D5 is
completely winning this wins a piece
this is the human move
this is the human move Queen takes D5
rookie 7 check is Checkmate black has to
part ways with a minor piece but
apparently there's also Knight takes F5
with the idea that after okay if Queen
F5 and queen d8 wins
nfgf then after Bishop takes D5 this is
a better version because here you're
threatening rookie seven
whereas here black can technically still
you know hold on with the move Rook E8
and you have to convert the extra piece
um but nobody if somebody plays Knight
takes F5 you can find the Arbiter so
after D6 apparently this gave black a
chance to stay in the game with Knight
C6 and of course the point is that now
Bishop F7 is impossible because the Rook
has protected another way
what I was planning here is the night
sacrifice on H5
night sacrifice on H5 and after GH Queen
takes H5 King G7
I think there is a quiet move here that
essentially ends the game who can tell
me what this move is what you should
notice is that you have the queen and
the bishop in the attack it's not quite
enough you need one more piece to
actually contribute its fill to to
fulfill its role in the attack the pod
on D6 has done its job you don't need it
anymore what you need a lot more is for
The Rook to dive into E6 Rook E1 is
winning yeah Queen takes D6 and I
actually think
you can play rookie 6 even here
check
here
and there are no more effective checks
there's only one other check you move up
to H2 and just there's way way too many
threats against the wide open black king
so yeah rookie one is good Rook D5 is
probably also good
although here I'm gonna go Rook f8 so
you're gonna have a hard time actually
getting your Rook past the F5 Pawn no I
think Rook D5 is very inaccurate I think
you have to play rookie one because here
black cannot stop you from getting to E6
of black tries then while you're just
gonna Advance it one square further
but
yeah so this was winning maybe not the
best but after night shape Bishop F7 the
game is over we win The Rook let me push
the pawn up to D7 you could also play
rookie one and rookie seven and F4 Queen
C7 Rook takes D5 and we promote to
another queen
man I feel like we played this is
probably one of my better quality games
in the speed run I don't usually do this
but I'm curious what the accuracy was
this is a depth 18 so it's not wow 95.4
that that's
yeah I'm giving myself a pat on the back
there that was a good game
um but I think the reason
we were able to play accurately is
because all of my moves were
pretty straightforward we were just
improving our position
there were a couple of
important moments that you can take away
from this game
um it was it was 80. Rook C5 is a really
good move
it's just one of those moves that
imperceptibly increases the pressure
dial on your opponent's position you
have to learn to make such moves if you
want to cross like the 202100 level
where it's like well what specifically
does this move do well there is it
specifically prepares D5 but it also
just creates unpleasant General pressure
on your opponent's position the other
thing is like once you have exhausted
all of your obvious improving moves oh
notice here also right don't just
automatically put your pieces on an open
file you have to
figure out whether in the future your
opponent is going to contest that file
and if he does who does the trade of
Rooks actually favor right so the reason
I refrained from Rook C1 is because
black wallpaper should be seven we have
to waste the tempo on defending it
uh E4 and now black plays Queen D7 and
Rook C8 on the next move
so and and then we might have to waste
the tempo keeping the Rooks on the board
so you might as well not play Rook C1 in
the first place and already get the Rook
to where it's going to go in the end
F3 and then once all of the Improvement
moves have been made this idea of
playing H4 and probing for weaknesses
even if you are castled on the same side
the move H4 is often a lot less of a
drastic measure than you might think it
is
Fearless One asks if when why did H4
what if black plays H5 well that's what
happened in the game
but you're saying you want to go King H7
we're not giving black time to blinking
H7 we're already trading the Bishops
here it is a it is a tough move to play
for lower rateds but if you understand
that like King safety is very relative
right when your king is surrounded by
pieces when your opponent's pieces are
passive you really shouldn't be afraid
uh to make the occasional move
in front of your own King and actually
one position I often give to students
lower rated students
and they really struggle with this
is this idea
this is a very typical idea but the way
that I applied it in the game gives a
lot of people trouble so just to finish
off this segment
take a look at this position from one of
my games years ago
so what you should notice about this
type of position is this Knight on G3
anytime there's a knight on G3 or B3 or
B6 or G6 there is a very typical idea
that is associated with
having a knight on G3 like that what
idea is what am I talking about what am
I talking about
yeah so you can try to chase the Knight
Away by pushing your Pawn to H4 now you
might say well here
that's out of the question because we're
castled to the king side it doesn't
matter that your Castle to the king side
because white species are very passive
and white is also going to Castle
kingside so here the best move is not H5
because that blunters upon but how do
you prepare it you start with G6 like
whoa pushing a pawn big deal castles and
H5
and notice that if white allows us to
play H4
then we're gonna chase the Knight all
the way back to H1 you're gonna get a
nice score for the bishop so this is
kind of really a no-brainer
my opponent played B4 I dropped the
Knight back I played H4 and you know
life went on my king is still perfectly
well defended and that's sort of one of
the key takeaways you shouldn't just
rule out moves that push pawns near your
king just because it looks weakening you
have to actually understand is it likely
to be weakening in the long run are you
likely to get punished for it
is this idea only relevant if the
opponent is passive or does it bend on
the exact situation no this is a very
ubiquitous idea
um which is applicable in a wealth of
different
positions
so I can give you another example of a
situation which the opposing side is a
little bit more active but you still
apply this idea
yeah so this position doesn't have
ostensibly too much in common with the
previous example
but the one thing you should see is this
again is there's this Knight on G3
but well H5 is illegal
H5 is illegal because there's a bishop
on H6 so there's an intermediate step
that has to be taken
and in order to take that step you need
to get the bishop off of H6 how do you
do that but how do you do that while
maintaining the pieces you want to
maintain you don't want to go Bishop G7
because you don't want to trade your
fianchetto King's Indian Bishop yeah
Knight F7 is correct very nice
now I hear a lot of people saying well
but aren't you moving the night away
from an active Square again
moving a piece away from a square is far
less committal of an act Than People
realize you can move the Knight to E5
later also you're opening up the e-file
who stands to benefit from that was
definitely black because black can
easily get both Rooks to the e-file
Bishop is chased away and here's that H5
move again
Bishop F1 H4 the Knight is pushed away
from G3 and now Knight H5 extending
Black's control over the king side and
amazingly this leads to almost an
immediate win because tamborine blunders
with Knight F4
and it only takes black two more moves
until white resigns who can find
how Bobby Nick wins the game and there
is a very tempting move here which I can
guarantee a lot of people are about to
suggest which is not correct the win is
actually quite straightforward
yep I was right
I read you guys like the like the palm
of my hand
yeah so of course Rook takes E3 is what
everybody wants to play
but if you calculate you'll see that
it's not correct Queen E3 oh but you win
the queen with Bishop T4 no you don't
white can sack The Exchange back on D4
and actually black is in horrible shape
here because you've ended up losing a
pawn and giving away your your main
Bishop
so the actual solution is just Knight
takes F4
Bishop takes F4 and you have to notice
that the bishop is almost out of squares
again you might say oh it's G5 Bishop B3
Rook takes E3 but no it's the same
problem after Queen takes C3 you don't
have Bishop D4
so instead you flip the move order what
do you start with here
you need to deprive white of the E3
Square can you do that with tempo
well yes you can right if you ask
yourself that question then you should
notice that the move is
let's hear it Bishop D4 check very good
and tamborine resigned
because after King H1 G5 black white
loses the bishop on F4
and so
this H5 H4 idea is is like an incredibly
incredibly uh widespread in a bunch of
different types of positions and I can
show you a million other examples but I
think that's probably enough for now
uh so yeah unless there are any other
questions
I will round off for today
asking yourself the right question this
is the hardest part yeah of course
that's the hardest thing about Chess in
general
um everything depends on the position
yeah but as you can see and hopefully
one thing I was able to properly show in
the speed run is that a lot of stuff is
generalizable like you really can
apply some of the same thinking patterns
and across many different types of
positions to produce reasonable moves
thanks for hanging out everybody have a
good start to the week I'll see y'all
later bye
[Music]